about 280 Canadians had their accounts
Frozen and so what that looked like was
my mother's stuck at the grocery store
checkout that had to leave their
groceries there which is a mortifying
experience in itself like you just said
you know parents that couldn't buy
medicine for their children couldn't pay
their mortgage couldn't pay their child
support I mean I was arrested and my
husband was in Ottawa we had a joint
account I mean we don't anymore but we
had a joint account so here he is in a
strange city he doesn't know anyone and
has no access to funds
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
one of the key organizers of the
Canadian trucker protests and author of
Hold the Line my story from the heart of
the freedom Convoy Tamara leech welcome
to the Reuben report thank you so much
for having me I am glad to have you you
came down to the free state of Florida
to do this we could have done it on
Skype yes but you wanted to feel a
little Freedom you wanted to breathe
that freedom that beautiful thing that
we have here didn't you absolutely yeah
it's a little different than what you
have going on it's very different very
different yes yeah so uh well let's just
start at the beginning because I suspect
that you did not intend maybe five years
ago to be a leader of a Canadian trucker
Convoy I don't think you intended to
have to write a book about it I don't
think you intended to have to have your
lawyer in the studio with us right now
and a bunch of other stuff so just tell
me a little bit about yourself and then
kind of what led you to the to the covid
moment where then you stepped into a
whole bunch of other stuff then we'll
spend most the interview talking about
that yeah sounds great
um well I was born and raised on the
Prairies in Canada so the Prairie
Provinces and predominantly work in oil
and gas so very heavy in the energy
sector there and it was through that
that I started to kind of wake up to
what was going on because the Canadian
government is really pushing this Net
Zero and they were crushing our economy
and they were putting through
legislation that was harming families
people were losing jobs and so I became
I guess an activist we started going to
rallies and stuff like that and of
course I also was following very closely
what was happening at a federal level
level with our politicians and then of
course covet hit and
um I'm not sure about what it was like
down in the States but in Canada it was
very dark and depressing we were
segregated you know I was told my
parents weren't even allowed in my own
home or my children which did not work
for me and people I knew and cared about
were getting affected you know the
suicides in my hometown were so numerous
they stopped reporting on them so and
and that's the kind of stories that we
heard you know going on across Canada so
I wanted to do something and get
involved and I made a phone call to
Chris Barber and now here I am so a lot
has transpired over the last couple
years and you know it was it was
interesting for me because you know
every day I wake up and there's another
story and especially during covid
another crazy thing happening but I was
noticing that more and more people from
Canada were tuning into the show when I
was just talking about the Kobe
craziness in the states and then
suddenly this Canadian trucker thing
happens and then it becomes kind of a
worldwide phenomenon so first can you
just talk a little bit more about how
Draconian all of the lockdowns and
everything were in Canada and you guys
you don't have a federal system like we
do so it was pretty much Countrywide it
was very much Countrywide we were
dealing with some
well our prime minister made the vaccine
vaccine wedge issue in the last election
and so he was like he came off like a
lunatic you know he was out there if
you're not vaccinated you can't get on a
train or a plane people were being
denied Medical Care uh in Quebec the
province of Quebec they were going to
initiate a vax tax
you know they had curfews in Quebec so
um and that was across the whole country
the stuff was happening and like I said
you know something so simple is you know
not being allowed to have your own
family in your own home you know people
lost their jobs they lost their
businesses uh loved ones were dying by
themselves in long-term care homes they
weren't even allowed to go in to say
goodbye to their dying parents
so you know it was unacceptable
unacceptable and something that I never
thought I would see happen in Canada you
know never before in our history have we
quarantined the healthy to save the
vulnerable so
what do you think was the breaking point
that got the trucker thing to get going
there uh because when people think about
Canada they think about John Candy and
they think about comedy and they you
know like Canada they think about
poutine and mounties and pleasant people
that just are you know I love going to
Canada like everyone's very pleasant and
nice and all that stuff
um you don't think of the Canadians as
being the people that are going to push
back and maybe that's what the
government was preying on actually yeah
I don't think that they saw that coming
at all so when the government of Canada
was going to initiate the trucker
mandate which was going to prevent
cross-border travel but wouldn't prevent
it what it was going to do was if you
did not have a vaccine passport then you
would have to go home and quarantine for
14 days and so along our border we have
a lot of truckers that are back and
forth daily you know they kind of take
that kind of a hit they couldn't afford
that kind of a hit
um and so they have families to feed and
so that was really the Catalyst that
started the whole whole thing and uh my
good friend Chris Barber did a tick tock
video calling for a shutdown on January
the 23rd and a lady trucker named
Bridget Belton from Ontario had reached
out to him and then this just this group
of small group of people came together
and you know we all had very similar
ideas and and uh in 10 days we organized
this entire thing and drove cross
country so you drive in cross country
and now the mainstream media is calling
you a bunch of racists and bigots and
Justin Trudeau said that you were trans
folks I mean it was it was really like
everything it was everything at once
what what was the hope like when you all
began the thing what was the hope really
to break the was it to break the
government was it to break through
though was it just to turn around on the
lockdowns like
the only reason we went was to end the
mandates that's it
um yeah there was lots of crazy rumors
that we were going to overthrow the
government and I mean it was it was you
guys were picking up trash after
yourselves like it was so ridiculously
peaceful it was amazing it was one of
the most beautiful experiences of my
life a beautiful show of humanity you
know everybody that came to the Convoy
was basically a volunteer because nobody
came there without donating something
bringing something contributing or
pitching in and like you said shoveling
snow or cleaning up garbage or you know
it was everyone was a volunteer everyone
was an organizer so the thing that I
think really put it on the map first
they're calling you racist and Vegas and
the rest of it but okay we've all we've
all been through that uh but then this
this bank account thing happens so talk
about that did you have any sense that
something like this was coming how did
that get laid out
as we were dealing with GoFundMe uh that
was the initial oh that was a funny
platform that we used and we had an
accountant come in and he was actually
trying to set up a bank account for us
to prevent that money from going in
because I just set it up to go into my
personal one of my personal bank
accounts
and so TD Bank was really dragging their
feet dragging their feet dragging their
feet so I I sensed that something was up
and then of course as soon as GoFundMe
released it they pretty much uh grabbed
it right away seized it immediately so
so basically GoFundMe was taking the
money
you were first so putting it to your
account but then you were like all right
I want to put this to the actual
separate account for the was it is it a
non-profit or what what was it well we
we did send set up a non-profit after
but at that time we didn't have a board
of directors we we did that actually in
Ottawa on the Fly creating the board of
directors so that we could make sure
that it was all managed and
um and then yeah TD shut you down before
because GoFundMe shot you down too right
we had a fantastic meeting actually with
GoFundMe on a Thursday night
our lawyers were there their lawyers
were there and we we left that meeting I
left that meeting anyways feeling very
hopeful like we'd answered all their
questions and the next afternoon they
froze the campaign
so yeah it was um and then
um credit to the governor of Florida I
hope I get to shake that man's hand one
day GoFundMe was going to they they came
out and said well if you request a
refund
we'll send it back if not then we're
going to send it to the organization of
our choice
people's donations yes criminal and it
was DeSantis that stood up and said um
no you don't you know so I mean yeah a
credit to him for doing that they ended
up having to refund it all right so can
you just talk about the type of people
that were donating and the type of
people that were showing up and and
everything else
just regular everyday people you know we
had um
it was really the most beautiful
beautiful experience like I said
Canadians from all across the country
like the West Coast the East Coast the
north we had truckers come down from
Northwest Territories even so
but it was you know the one of the most
um telling things for me was on the
ground there it was really a jubilant
atmosphere
um people were hugging and crying and
you know I was talking to total
strangers and it was the Immigrant
population so immigrants from Iran
Poland Romania all these countries that
would come up to me and they would just
have this look of desperation in their
eyes very telling you know they were
they'd seen this coming they've lived
through it already
it was kids and senior citizens and just
everyday people you know federal
government employees were there doctors
nurses uh lawyers ex law enforcement
former firefighters you know everyone so
they come in they kick you off GoFundMe
they freeze the bank account but then
they started freezing the bank accounts
of the people that donated people that
in some cases donated what 15 bucks I
think the average donation was 50 bucks
yeah and then they're freezing the bank
accounts of these people who then can't
get medicine can't go about their daily
business literally cannot withdraw money
from their ATMs
about 280 Canadians had their accounts
Frozen and so what that looked like was
my mother's stuck at the grocery store
checkout that had to leave their
groceries there which is a mortifying
experience in itself like you just said
you know parents that couldn't buy
medicine for their children couldn't pay
their mortgage couldn't pay their child
support I mean I got I was arrested and
my husband was in Ottawa we had a joint
account I mean we don't anymore but we
had a joint account so here he is in a
strange city he doesn't know anyone and
has no access to funds
so what were you actually arrested for
uh I was originally arrested on a charge
of counseling to commit mischief
and then they had to admit just because
yeah counseling
counsel to commit an offense that never
happened right right so they added a
mischief charge uh intimidation
counseling intimidation which as I said
I'm not very intimidating person right
and there's two more I think one is uh
disobey a police order and something
else I don't know right and where are
you with all of that now uh we have a
trial coming up so Chris and I are
co-accused and we have a trial starting
in the fall so I'll be going to Ottawa
around the end of August we got a 16 day
trial over the course of six weeks for
Miss Jeff right and because I mentioned
that your lawyers here and he did say to
you beforehand I'm not here to tell you
what to say you tell your story
um
what what do you want people to know
before I suppose you go to trial so that
you know because a lot of this had to do
with public pressure it seems to me
Trudeau only broke because of public
pressure because suddenly those videos
millions and millions of people were
seeing that you guys were not burning
down the cities like we had seen here in
America and you were not bad guys and
racists and white supremacists and the
rest of it and they sure tried to paint
it that way yeah so in the fall of last
year so anytime the emergencies Act is
invoked in Canada within 365 days they
have to have an investigation
so last fall we went to Ottawa again for
seven weeks to testify I testified there
and um
the evidence that came out of their
the superintendent for the Ottawa or
sorry Ontario Provincial Police in the
intelligence Department
said the lack of evidence was or the
lack of violence was shocking and he
also said that what he was hearing
coming from the politicians in the media
was not lining up with the intelligence
that they were getting so it was
incredible but our mainstream doesn't
cover that stuff so that's the kind of
information that we want to get out is
the actual evidence that came out to
show that we weren't violent they were
um they were issuing internal memos in
the government saying that we were
entering Federal buildings and causing
destruction like the the lies the lies
the bold-faced lies was quite shocking
yeah well can you talk about the media
component of this because you know for
as horrible as our mainstream media here
corporate presses in the United States I
mean you guys have the CBC it's it's
fully state funded I would argue
propaganda I'm guessing you probably
don't disagree with me but then I was
seeing guys on the ground like Ezra
Levant over at Rebel news who they were
deeply embedded with you guys and plenty
of other people they're independent
they're under attack now too
well and thank God for our independent
journalists and as the citizen
journalists too like yeah Rebel news was
there they were amazing True North was
there they were amazing uh there were so
many of them and and I mean the CBC is
literally I think two blocks from where
the protest was
so and and so they could see right but
they weren't coming down and telling the
whole story and for the life of me was
there anyone on CBC or any any
mainstream channel that was giving you a
fair shake to go on these shows and no
nobody no no
um no not none of them they they had
painted their narrative that's more
evidence that came out they had painted
that narrative before I even met Chris
Barber got in big red and we left
so they were colluding the government
was already colluding with our
mainstream media and you're right I mean
the CBC is the one that came out and
suggested that we were being influenced
by the Russians and I remember I looked
at Chris Barber I was like I don't even
know if I know any Russians you know you
probably hugged some out of the streets
we sure did what was it ultimately that
that broke Trudeau on this when he
finally turned around one day because it
really seemed like he wasn't gonna stop
and then and then eventually it did the
pressure got released a little bit well
I think what happened are you referring
to when he revoked the ACT yeah when
well basically at some point there was I
don't know was that when he revoked the
actor at some point basically the
truckers were there they sort of it was
you guys were all sort of at an impasse
and didn't he was that when he revoked
the actor no well what he did instead
was invoked what is akin to martial law
in Canada the emergencies act right so
that was the emergency that's right but
what then broke it after that well I
think a lot of it had to do with the
banks because people were seeing that
these bank accounts were getting Frozen
and they were going and pulling their
money out you know tens of thousands
like millions of dollars and I think
that he got some pressure from the banks
to to revoke this thing has there been
any Reckoning with Trudeau within the
party or within Canadian politics
altogether I mean I know you guys have a
sort of somewhat dysfunctional
conservative party and you know things
never really seem to materialize on that
side but there's been no Reckoning with
any of this not yet no but but I am
hopeful that that come I mean I I know
that the inquiry is over but you know
there's still some legal things
happening there they just did a judicial
review of the invocation of the
emergencies act so we're waiting for
that decision now so I'm really hoping
that he can be held accountable for for
his decision to
have law enforcement beat up our
veterans
our veterans grandmothers you know and
it was such a peaceful beautiful protest
and the footage that came out afterwards
I was in jail obviously I didn't see it
firsthand but
I mean I got home and I sat on my crowd
couch and I just cried like a baby
watching all that footage
you know these people getting arrested
and and left in transport vehicles for
hours with their hands zip tied behind
their back driven to the outskirts of
Ottawa and dropped off in a snow bank
you know it was it was heartbreaking
uh in the winter I was in jail for 18
days and then I was rearrested last
summer on an alleged breach charge
so I did 30 days in prison uh last
summer too what has this taught you
about your fellow citizens kind of good
good and bad I suppose
well I used to sit on the board of
directors for a Western Federal
independence party we created this this
political party out of nothing basically
and so for me the biggest eye-opener was
you know we've always had kind of a
East-West divide in Canada right and um
you know we're always told that they
were just a bunch of hillbillies and
they don't want our dirty oil and all
that stuff so my biggest eye-opening
experience to begin with was I'm sitting
at my kitchen table we'd all been sent
home because it was Omicron
sitting at my kitchen table and I got my
two monitors on on my table and I've got
we had Road captains from every province
that would lead like a contingent of
trucks in and so I've got these chats
open and I'm talking to the road captain
from Quebec and she has like a thousand
trucks ready to go and these guys are
beautiful and supportive and I thought
this has all been a lie like the this
has all been to divide us and it was not
so not true and then after we shortly
after we got there
um one of the first pictures I saw was a
quebecois holding their flag and an
albertan holding our flag and them
shaking hands and
I mean that was such an amazing
astonishing thing to see yeah you know
like the unity that happened it didn't
matter what color your skin was it
didn't matter what God you worshiped it
didn't matter who you loved it didn't
matter what your income bracket was we
were all just Canadians
and for the last eight years that man
has been doing nothing but to try and
divide us along all of those lines
do you think he's it's hard you know he
only got what 30 of the vote something
like that like 31. do you think he's
actually convincing people that he's
right or is it just that Canadians
generally are just nice so they they
don't step up that these moments don't
happen that often I I don't know people
ask me like why do you keep electing him
and I said like are we though like I
don't know if you know what's going on
up there right now but we're
in deep in some serious Chinese
interference allegations they've been
interfering in our elections and stuff
so I mean is he getting elected I don't
know I guess they're dragging their feet
on that too of course he tried to once
again get one of his buddies to
investigate himself and uh that actually
didn't work out too good for him but now
they've broke for the summer so
it's just astonishing so when they
reverse this thing and they reverse the
emergency Powers Act and all that then
the bank accounts were open and then
they did they start leaving people alone
I mean did they drop K obviously you're
going through the case still do they
drop cases against people or I don't
know if they've dropped any charges
against people
um maybe one case but they're they've
they're pursuing them
pretty well especially in me and Chris's
case very very talk like they're hard
they're coming after us hard yeah what I
always ask guests that somehow you know
a certain set of people just kind of
step into these things they don't intend
to undo it at least you know some people
set out to do something some people kind
of step into it you strike me as like
the step into it type person what do you
think is it is about you that kind of
makes you want want to do this or have
to do this or well I I love my country I
mean I grew up fascinated with Americans
and their and their passion for their
their flag and their patriotism you know
for me that was so admirable and so that
was something that I experienced for the
first time driving across Canada and
meeting all those people you know so
it's worth saving you know we were just
talking before we started here about all
the people that are leaving Canada
fleeing Canada which is two words I
never thought I'd hear in the same
sentence but if we all leave then who's
it's worth fighting for and the people
people are so good you know it was it
was a very for me a very Divine and
spiritual experience
and the unity that I saw just made me
love it even more are you seeing a lot
of people flee Canada right now I
mentioned you right before we started I
mean I'm seeing a ton of Canadians you
know Canadians are snowbirds down in
Florida usually but I'm meeting more and
more people that are like oh I'm
actually not going back this is it now
there's a lot of them a lot of good
people too like our doctors our nurses
you know uh police like her
professionals
so that's it's quite alarming did this
change any of your politics in terms of
capitalism socialism you guys have more
socialized medicine that sort of thing
it seemed like some new lines were drawn
in regards to those things as well no I
think I think I've always been a very
conservative minded and and um I
certainly
have never voted liberal in 30 years
probably
um
well because they had a big scandal in
the 2000s you probably heard about the
sponsorship Scandal and that was kind of
when I really started paying attention
to politics and following it a little
bit more closely and I was just
disgusted
there's never been any arrests over that
like billions of Canadians taxpayers
dollars you know and nothing so
so yeah I know I think I'll continue to
be a conservative minded the machine has
a way of just going on and on that's why
I was asking about you know is there any
Reckoning for Trudeau or anything
because we have that here in the states
it's like no matter how many times they
lied about the mandates lied about the
efficacy of the vax or how
unconstitutional lockdowns were anything
else nobody gets fired no nobody gets
fired it's a weird realization you know
it is it really is
um are you hopeful that things can turn
around in Canada I am yeah so where does
the Hope come from
well again I mean my belief in the
Canadian people like they all came
together in in such an amazing way and
you know we can make a change we just
proved that you know like I said this
was just such an organic movement it
literally started off with a handful of
people
and I mean within 24 hours we realized
holy cow you know when we were talking
about setting the target for the
GoFundMe Chris had said well I think it
was 200 or 250 000 and I'm like no way
don't be ridiculous I said
I'll set it for a hundred thousand and
and I don't even think we'll hit that
like in the back of my mind I thought
maybe 20 grand they would drive across
Canada stand there with their sign get
back in their trucks and drive home and
within 24 hours you know that we blew
past a hundred thousand dollars
and so you know the support the support
was incredible and like I said it just
it was so organic and it just came from
nothing and then all of a sudden boom
and while the politicians will not
acknowledge that what the truckers did
change things you know before we even
left provinces we're talking about
lifting their mandates
so so it was it was working when you get
people out there doing the right thing
you know it's interesting I was just
thinking as you were saying this we
played a video about two weeks ago on my
show where outside of the prime
minister's office they took down the
Canadian flags and they put up the uh
the trans flag or whatever that is it's
like these things really are connected
in a very bizarre way do you do you see
that yeah oh I think it's all connected
everything the the climate emergency or
you know that we're supposedly under all
of it I I think it's all connected yeah
how much are you guys so you mentioned a
little bit about the the energy makers
in the west and the sort of energy
takers in these how much of that
affected all of this as well just the
way the country split in that sense well
I mean a lot of the stuff with the oil
and gas industry
if I'm understanding your question
correctly you know they wanted to build
a pipeline across Canada and the
quebecois said no way you know and so
that we could get our product out there
and keep it in Canada you know what I
mean instead they import oil from
uh Saudi Arabia and these other
countries you know that some of them
have some very horrible human rights
abuses yeah you know and that just
boggles my mind you know I worked in
that industry I know it's not dirty I
mean Canada has one of the most
environmentally friendly and and
efficient energy Industries in the world
we should be a Beacon of Hope for other
countries and and our politicians should
be you know shouting that from the
rooftops and advocating for it and
instead they're just trying to shut us
down you know and and the province that
I live in it's pretty our
resources is oil and gas like that's
that's our main resource so that affects
a lot of human beings they're not just
numbers yeah these are people that are
losing their homes and losing their jobs
and a lot of them without these jobs
it's you know some of the the life out
there uh it's the tundra basically I
mean it's not it's not as if there's a
million other reasons to be out there
it's for the energy yeah yeah well it's
a beautiful Province it's absolutely
gorgeous gorgeous Province yeah yeah
um what else should people know about
what you guys were doing and where the
fight's going and well I think the most
important thing for me and one of the
reasons why I felt this book was so
important was that
the freezing of the bank accounts was
huge and you know Canada is the most
polite and passive country on the planet
as far as I'm concerned so you know if
they can do that in Canada they can do
it anywhere anywhere at all there was no
parliamentary oversight there was no
court order from a judge it was just
boom and nobody from the banks even
resisted
like there's notes in our finance
minister Christoph freelands dossier
that that came out as evidence saying
label them as terrorists and seize their
assets
like
it's mind-boggling the lengths that they
went to to try and paint us as well
January 6 style insurrectionists yeah
that's what they wanted you know so I
think it's it's an important read it's
an important story
um it's a beautiful story of humanity
and I'm just so proud of how it all
turned out yeah well and you're still in
the midst of it yes I suppose we'll see
how it all turns out yes that's right
but I assume you're hopeful that the uh
charges will just be dismissed and
that'll be it and that would be nice but
um they've been very eager
and like I said last summer I was picked
up on an alleged breach charge
um and spent 30 days in jail after I was
denied bail initially then also so they
don't seem to be letting up and I think
they want to make an example of us to
tell it's intimidation
but uh they picked the wrong grandma
so and by the way they weren't until
recently I mean unboxed Canadians
couldn't even get out of the country no
no they did reverse that right people
can now get out yeah it's one thing to
not let people in but to not let people
out yes that's uh that's a gross
infringement on you yes are you are you
raising funds now for any of the legal
stuff or anything else yeah well I'm
very lucky
um the Democracy fund is funding my
criminal case and we're we're also doing
donations because we have a civil suit a
406 million dollar civil suit against us
also so um and the jccf from Canada
civil suit from uh it's from a lawyer in
in Ottawa
basically that when we had started off
as 10 million dollars so we get to
Ottawa at the Convoy and we've raised 10
million dollars in donations which is
unheard of and all of a sudden we have a
10 million dollar lawsuit right and so
what this gentleman did was he started
yeah I know so weird and uh so then he
sent some minions out into the crowd to
go find people to put on this lawsuit
for him so that has grown now to 406
million dollar class action suit against
me and a number of other organizers
even though you're right it was honking
horns even though again you guys were
cleaning up and shoveling snow and
purchasing things at the stores without
burning the stores down yes model
protesters so we were raising funds for
that so that we can you know do start
doing get a bit more aggressive start
you know doing some motions and stuff
like that so
so yeah
um
yeah and you're not going to move to
Florida that's my last question you're
going to fight it out you're going to
find out we were talking right before
about how there's a value in fighting
and staying and all that and sometimes
there's a value in Moving on but you're
you're in the fight and stay mode I'm in
the thick of it now I can't leave now
although I do really like Miami I will
definitely be back here yeah yeah what a
beautiful city and Beautiful People well
we will link to uh the appropriate uh is
it what site is it now it's not GoFundMe
obviously Howard uh the Democracy fund
the democracy is the link to that we'll
link to that and then the convoybook.com
is where you can find the book and
that's also on Amazon and also yeah and
Canadian truckers rule according to Elon
Musk yes he's right over there I mean
that must have been something when you
that was crazy seeing all of these major
people that were supporting you that you
know you had no idea that was even
president Trump had said something about
the truckers yeah oh yeah that was
pretty
surreal yeah very surreal well thanks
for coming down to the free state of
Florida and I wish you a lot of luck
thank you on this adventure and if if it
all starts up again I will still be
talking about it thank you thanks for
having me too really appreciate that
yeah if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
international issues check out our
International playlist and if you want
to watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell